-I love watching you
on the Knicks
and I love seeing you
and I do --
A lot of New Yorkers out there,
we care about the Knicks.
You care about the Knicks.
I don't think anyone cares more
than your 6-year-old son, Kyden.
-Correct. Yes.
-He really, really is passionate
about the Knicks,
if they win or lose.
-Very passionate.
He's -- Everybody thinks,
you know,
playing in New York is hard.
And, you know,
you lose a couple games,
and the media beats on you
and all that different
type of stuff.
Try a car ride home
with my son after a game.
-Really?
-Yeah.
He -- I mean, it was --
I think it was last year.
We had -- I think we maybe won
like 8 or 9 games in a row.
And --
-Let me show who --
-Yes. That's my baby.
-This is the guy
you were talking about.
That's my baby.
-Alright, so,
you're driving home, yeah?
-Yes. Yeah.
Yeah. Driving home.
And, you know, we had lost the
game after 8 or 9 in a row,
and he was super-upset
because I guess
he wanted a 20-game win streak.
I don't know.
And he told me I should ask
for a trade after that.
-He's like, "I don't know, dad.
I don't know, dad.
I don't think they're
supporting you, dad."
-Yeah, yeah.
So, yeah, try try a car ride
home with my son.
It's tough.
-I want to give everyone
an idea of how much
your son cares
about the Knicks.
This is Kyden Randle after the
Knicks lost a preseason game,
by the way.
This is preseason.
-Not the real thing.
-No. Take a look at this.
-[ Crying ]
I don't want to lose.
-Ky, it's just preseason.
-I don't care is it's preseason!
-There's still a chance.
-No, there's not!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?
-Oh, man.
-He's so cute.
He's a cute kid, man.
He's a good kid.
-Yeah, he's the best.
He's the best.
-I have a picture of you
as a kid here,
wearing a Kobe jersey
right there.
-Absolutely.
-And...
[ Applause ]
Kind of cool you got
to play with Kobe.
-I did. I got to play with Kobe.
As you can see in that picture,
that was my idol growing up.
-And this is you and Kobe.
This is your rookie year.
Look at this. How -- Come on.
-Absolutely.
I mean, come on. This kid --
-Unreal. Unreal.
Who would have thought?
-What was he like?
What was Kobe --
Have you got any Kobe stories?
What was he...
-So, this was my first game
back -- in the NBA,
back in my hometown of Dallas.
And, you know, I get there
and I'm excited to go home.
My mom's there. She's cooked.
-Yeah.
You got to see your friends.
-Get to see my friends.
-"Look -- I made it, guys."
-Yeah, party.
You guys are coming to watch me
play tomorrow here, right?
So, I get there,
and Kobe's like,
"No, no, no, no, no.
We're going to the gym
and we're going to
get a workout in.
And, yeah, you can kiss
and wave your hi, you know,
to your family later,
but, you know, right now,
we're going to get the work in."
And, unfortunately, after his
passing, I went to the gym --
Shortly after that,
I went to a gym in Detroit.
And the guy who opened up the
gym for me the night before --
he was like,
"Man, nobody ever does this."
He was like, "The last person
who did this was Kobe."
-Is that right?
-And -- You know what I mean?
So his spirit is strong.
It's alive and well.
-Thanks for telling that.
I appreciate that.
[ Applause ]
I got to say, you're amazing
to watch on the court.
You're intimidating to watch.
And I go to the --
I go to the games --
-Me intimidating?
-Yeah.
Yeah, and I look.
I don't want to make eye contact
with you when I go to the game,
because I don't want to
throw you off or have you,
like, "Dude,
get Jimmy Fallon out of here,
because that's why
I'm not doing well."
-No, no, no, no, no, no.
-Like, I don't want to say,
"Hi, how are you?",
or do anything.
I just want you to just play.
-We're best friends.
Let's come up with a handshake.
You're good. We're good.
-Yeah. We'll come up
with a cool handshake?
-Let's do it.
-So if I go to the game,
I can just go, "Hey, what's up?
-We got,
"Hey, what's up?", and...
Let me get a...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Something like that?
-That's the handshake.
-That's the handshake?
Just once.
-Just once. Just once.
-That's it. That's it.
That's the handshake. We got it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is...
Hey, it's a new season.
You have a new
sneaker partnership.
Tell us about
what you're doing with Skechers.
-You go to work, you want to
work with really good people,
and, you know,
that's the biggest thing.
It's an amazing shoe.
I was really surprised.
You know, I put the shoe on.
I was working out
in the shoe in the summer,
and I was like, "Man, this is
the most comfortable shoe
I've ever worn."
So I'm excited.
They're doing great stuff.
They're innovative.
They're creative.
-This is you destroying someone.
I'm sorry that...
Dunking over this --
There's the shoe.
But --
-What's going on?
-What's going on
in this guy's head?
That's me
when I was at the game.
Yeah, I meant to give you --
What happens after you
do something like this?
You have to apologize to him?
-No. "This is part of the
business, man." I don't know.
-Wow! That's right!
You go, "Yeah, go to the gym."
-Yeah.
-Go to the gym, dude.
-Nothing personal.
Nothing personal.
I actually got you something.
You know, I'm saying, you know,
this is new,
and you like that picture.
If you wear these right here --
Okay?
Like those? There you go.
-This is what I'm talking about.
-Yes. If you wear those, you
will be able to do just that.
-I can do just that.
That's what I'm talking about.
-I promise you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Guys, Julius Randle, everybody.
The Knicks kick off their season
this Wednesday
against the Boston Celtics.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.